[Applause]
it's in our genes
[Music]
it's in our blood
everything that's needed in rugby is
sort of incorporated in a fijian when
it's born
people still can't believe that fijians
are really really good at rugby
[Music]
[Music]
my name is david anno nakutonga
and i'm the founder of firm of the rugby
club
yamada rugby is an initiative to give a
second chance to unemployed youths and
minimize the drug use around the
province of navosa
rugby would be one thing that will take
their mind away from doing all those
things and get them to do something
positive in their lives
we have limited resources
we train using what we have we use logs
we use tyres we use anything and
everything
what we do makes us stronger and sort of
tougher because
guys get to work even harder than the
the guys with those modern resources
what we're trying to achieve is to get
the boys into the wider world of rugby
we've played tournaments in fiji samoa
australia
and paris in europe as well
when one of my club members get a
contract and play in tournaments my
whole body is just
so excited
my heart it's just full of joy oh my
goodness it's just so good feels so good
[Music]
rugby has changed my life in a way that
now i'm able to provide opportunities to
other people
i can give back to fiji as a whole so
rugby is a life changer
[Music]
you